Jerich Stewart il a passé la moitié de
sa vie en prison il ne contrôle pas ses
pulsions il manque totalement d'empathie
pour qui que ce soit pour quoi que ce
soit il ne ressent
[Musique]
rien vous savez qui je
suis vous vous appelez B vous êtes un
agent de la
c
que un programmateur hollandais vous
deviez le protéger vous vous rappelez
vous l'avez mis en sécurité mais où
l'avez-vous emmené c'est tout ce qu'on
veut
savoir on a besoin que vous vous
rappeliez je me rappelle
rien ils ont mis votre mari dans ma tête
il voulaient des infos qu'il détenait
avant se faire
butter c'est votre dernière chance où
ils mourront Washington Berlin Pékin
seront des cimetières les gens
comprendront qu'il y a un meilleur moyen
de diriger ce
monde il y a trop de VI en jeux elle ne
compte pas pour moi elle
compte ils se sont servis de moi
en pensant pouvoir me
contrôler mais ils ont
[Musique]
d